you have an itch on the left they want
to control Behavior a lot we saw the
same thing with covet a lot of that
wasn't about your health it was about
they wanted to control your behavior so
they just don't want people to be happy
and be able to make their own decisions
they were going after gas stoves in
Florida we made them tax-free we may
have to do some incentives for the Coal
Fire Pizza because you know what uh
we'll take it they're going to want us
to microwave this pizza so you're wrong
okay and there's Ron DeSantis eating
pizza eating pizza you know you're
really angering liberals when you eat
pizza on Fox news from a studio in New
York City this is supposed to make the
guy likable in some way this is supposed
to show us that
he's right on some policy issue it is
just pathetic